[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
WESTON KRUKOW: When
I dance, nothing else
is happening in the world, and
to be able to have that freedom
is incredible, and
I just get so happy.
I think internally,
at first, at barre,
I'm getting into my body.
I'm trying to lift
out of my hips.
I'm trying to really reach
and work on my footwork.
And then, by the time
that I start warming up
and I'm understanding what I'm
doing, then I start to project.
And I start to think, how can
I make this movement bigger,
and how can I show what I'm
feeling inside on the outside?
I teach the men at the
University of Arizona School
of Dance program.
I teach them the ballet.
--halfway.
See how it centers halfway.
Ah!
That's what I'm talking about.
And now with that hand--
oh, that's beautiful.
WESTON KRUKOW:
Every day I come in,
and he's ruthlessly
working on our technique.
JAMES CLOUSER: The
attitude towards ballet
is an interesting thing
with young men today
because they come
from a background
where ballet is
something a little bit
foreign, a little bit elite,
a little bit fancy-pantsy,
and they come from a milieu
where street dance is
what turns them on.
JORY HANCOCK: Here at the
University of Arizona,
one of the most unusual
things about our program
is that we have so many men.
Now, we're up to 45 or 50 men
out of 150 total students.
That's more men than any other
dance program in the country.
GIANNI HOWELL: Where I'm from,
we had guys at our studio,
but there was,
maybe, one or two.
So coming to a school where
there's 50 guy dancers,
it's almost like a new
experience in dance
all on its own.
I chose the
University of Arizona
because of their wide program.
They have tap.
They have jazz, ballet,
modern, musical theater.
And me, being
primarily a tap dancer,
that couldn't please
me more because now I'm
getting every single technique
in this one school, while also
on a beautiful campus.
DAVID MAURICE JOHNSON:
For 15 years, I ran track.
I sustained an injury my
senior year of high school,
was put into ballet class as
rehabilitation, and loved it.
When I graduate, I
just want to dance,
in every aspect of the
word-- just choreography,
teaching, performing,
traveling, getting lost
in the adventure of this
career and life choice.
WESTON KRUKOW: I came
in really confident
in ballet, loving jazz--
I've done that the longest--
no experience in modern.
And what U of A has given me is
an unbelievable, well-rounded
knowledge.
JORY HANCOCK: The
students in this program
are so dedicated
to their art form.
So they're really focused
on dance, but many of them
are double majors in
engineering, business, pre-med.
So it's important for them to
be in a conservatory environment
like the U of A school
of dance but on a campus
that is a Research I university.
GIANNI HOWELL: I want to
dance for the rest of my life,
but I also decided
to minor in business
because when I'm done dancing,
I want to own a competition.
I want to own a studio.
And just in case anything
happens with dance,
I always have that
minor the fall back on.
JORY HANCOCK: The Stevie
Eller Dance Theater
is a state of the art facility
with beautiful sprung floors,
a nice big stage, a small house,
so the audience is right there.
It's very intimate.
And because it is
a small house, we
get to do a lot of
performances, so our dancers
are on stage 40 or
50 times a year.
Like any science lab would be,
for us, this is our laboratory.
[APPLAUSE]